وانضم الينا رئيسه الاستخبارات الافغانيه
السابقه رحمه الله نبيل اهلا بك معنا في
العربيه 360 سيد رحمه الله يعني اود ان
ابدا حديث معك اليوم بمعرفه رايك بما مرت
به افغانستان
بالعامين المصريين وما هي اهم الاخطاء
التي وقعت بها حكومه اشرف غني واوصلت
البلاد الى ما هي عليه الان
سنه سعيده معكم في هذا البرنامج
سمح لطالبان بان تقبل على انها تغيرت وكان
هناك توقعات من الافغانيين والمجتمع
الدولي بان ربما حركه طالبان قد تغيرت
حقيقه
عام
1996 في الفتره من 1996 و 2000 ولكنه ذلك
لم يحدث
في السلام بالوكاله ادى الى ما يشبه الحرب
بالوكاله في افغانستان حيث ان هناك يربوا
على 20 جماعه ارهابيه في افغانستان في
الوقت الراهن وفي الوقت ذاته نحن نعاني
همم من انتهاكاته حقوق الانسان وحرمان
الفتيات من الالتحاق بالمدارس والنساء من
العمل والان همم
النساء
لابنائهن ثم هناك انتهاكات لي حقوق الى
قليات والقائمه تطول همم
طالبا وضعت افغانستان في وضع صعب للغايه
ودفع نيسان الى حافه الحرب الاهليه او
الحرب بالوكاله
نعم
جماعه اخرى زياده
مع الافغان المتواجدين في خارج افغانستان
ومع شباب او النخبه الافغانيه من الشباب
هؤلاء يا شباب هم نتيجه ما حصل في
افغانستان خلال 20 عاما وتوصلنا الى خلاصه
بانه يجب ان يكون لدينا
من نص السياسيه
قاعده سياسيه تسمح لنا بالتواصل مع
الاحزاب السياسيه الاخرى لدعوتها للوحده
لانه في الوقت الراهن نعتقد ان حركه
الطالبان لن
تخشى العمليات الانتحاريه وانما ما تخشاه
طالبا همم هو الوحده وبالتالي نحن ندعو
الى الوحده مع كافه يافا اللون السياسي في
افغانستان اذا نحن مع الاحزاب السياسيه
الاخرى ان تشاطر الرعاء
نحن سوف نعمل في الخطوه الثانيه الى دعوه
كافه منظمات المجتمع المدني والاحزاب
وكذلك الافراد
للتشكيل لجبهه موحده همم
المكونات وذلك بقيه التوصل الى حلول
للاوضاع في افغانستان وبعد ذلك اذا راينا
بينا هذه الخطوه غير مقبوله همم سيكون
علينا ان نناقش ما هي الخطوه التاليه او
الخطوه البديله لاننا نحن الافغان ينتمون
الكثير من القلق بشان الاوضاع في
افغانستان ومستقبل الاجيال القادمه
وعدت همم بعد تسلمها الحكم بافغانستان
بانها ستغير نعجه ما الذي حصل حتى الان لا
تنفك عن حرمان المراه الافغانيه من حقها
في التعليم حقها في العمل من حريه التنقل
وحرمان كل الشعب الافغاني من ابسط حقوقه
ما الذي حصل حتى غيرت موقفها
لان الحركه جاءت من
تفسير خاصه للدين الاسلامي
وعلاوه على ذلك فان همم حركه طالبان عمدت
الى غسل لادمغه
وقالت لهم ان من يلتحقوا بالمدارس
الجامعات ويعملونهم ليسوا بالمسلمين وين
باقي ان يقتل والان الحركه تتمنى نفسه
التفكير في العقيده هي نفسها ولم تتغير
لدى هذه الحركه وبالتالي
خطرا ليس بالنسبه الى افغانستان
سوف تقوم تغذيه الفكر
المتطرف ليس في افغانستان فقط وانما في
بلدان اخرى
اذا وقد رفضت حركه طالبان دعوات من جميع
ارجاء العالم من جامع الازهر من السعوديه
ومن تركيا رفضت كل الدعوات التي تلقتها
لان هذا تصر على تبني تفسيرها
للاسلام وتطبقه في افغانستان وهذا يمثل
خطرا على مستقبل افغانستان
وبلدان الاسلاميه
ولكن بعض الافراد كانوا يقولون طالبان قد
تغيرت ولكن الان نرى ان تغيير لم يحصل
بالعكس حركه طالبان تتبنى نهج متشددا
الحياه
وكذلك
همم والافغان المتعلمين وباسبب ذلك فان
المتعلمين الافغان قد فروا من همم البلاد
لانهم لا يرون اي مستقبلي لهم في البلاد
همم غدا اسالك عن الدعوه التي وجهتها منذ
قليل الى الوحده مع كافه الاطراف التي
تشارككم همم يعني همم الراي تشارككم اللون
همم دعوت المنظمات منظمات المجتمع المدني
الاحزاب هل تتوقع ان يعني ترى ردا ايجابيا
ان تلقى هذه الدعوه سدا جيدا وتعاونا يعني
بظل سياسه زرع الخوف
والترهيب الممارسه ضد الجميع ضد الشعب
الافغاني هل يمكن ان
يتجاوبوا معكم
ايهاب اكزاكتلي بيقوللي
الواقع ان الافغان قد تواصلوا مع الناس
ولقد لقينا سيلا من التعليقات
لاننا اولا قمنا
بالنشر تشكيل هذا الحزب في
الراي العام الافغاني لم نلجا الى التركيز
على القمه مركزنا القاعده لاننا نتشاطر في
الالم وعلينا ان نعمل معا من اجلي الوصول
الى حلول
المشترك كافه
العمريه كلها هؤلاء يعانون وبالتالي
تلاقين استجابه ايجابيه هو الخطوه التاليه
بعد تشكيل ال- ال- القياده مجلس الق جافي
هذا الحزب و نحن لا نريد ان نملي اي همم
تشكيله محدده نريد مشاركه الشعب في هذه
التشكيله ونحن نتواصل ايضا مع الكثير من
الاحزاب السياسيه والجماعات والمهمه
الثالثه التي تسعى الى تنفيذها بعد تشكيل
هذه الجبهه الموحده هو الدخول في حوار
لماذا اخفقنا على الدوام في افغانستان
قلنا انه نعم يمكن ان نشرك المناطق
الريفيه في همم شان السياسي وكذلك في
اداره شؤونني
وكذلك شؤون البلاد وذلك من خلال انتخابات
تجرى في الاقاليم همم حكام الاقاليم ينبغي
ان ينتخبوا كان بالنسبه لرؤساء البلديات
لاننا يجب ان نمهد طريقا مزدوج لهذه
المشاركه لانه في السابق كان طريق
اتجاه واحد
فالركز كان هو الذي يفرض القواعد على
المناطق الريفيه وخلال مثلا ال- ال-
النظام
الشيوعي فان القرى كانت مشتته
الامر الذي سمح للمجادين باستغلال الوضع
ضد المركز وهذا حدث ايضا مع طالبان نحن
نقول اذا انه ينبغي علينا ان نكون قادرين
اقتراح شيء بناء على الدروس التي تعلمناها
على الرغم لاننا لسنا
قادرين همم نعطي حلول
المختلفه على الطاوله نناقشها في ما بيننا
بدلا من الانتظار من الاخرين ان يعتنوا
بشؤون افران علينا تكفل بهذا الامر
بانفسنا
ونقتني مع هذه الفرصه من اجل تسويه
مشكلاتنا اولا ونتناقش فيما بيننا
ونبحث عن سبب وراء اخفاق دولتنا طيله سنين
عديده
الاستخبارات الافغانيه السابقه شكرا